making his 10th start on the season
making his third start against chicago
here in 2020 made the opening day start
and woodruff struck him out 97 and
elevated yeah that high fastball has
been a really good pitch for woodruff
john lester making his ninth start yeah
it's been a rough go for leicester as of
late last five
starts a 9 26 earned run average last
time out against st louis garcia hits
one into left center of base hit big
turn around first to put on the brakes
and it's a lead off knock and the
brewers pick up right where they left
off in detroit and the three two to hero
swing at a missed rank three
lester strikes out kesten hera out
number one no score bottom of the first
a man at first and the batter now is
christian yellish swinging a miss got
him on the curve back-to-back k's of
hira and yelich
chase that breaking ball down in the way
and a good stop by nottingham another
strikeout for brandon woodruff
starting to stop and a swing and a miss
at the breaking ball from brandon
woodruff
big strikeout for woody
got him looking fastballed at 99.
99 right on the corner
brian mikkologic was
the dj that day as harshly rips one into
left center field that's down to base
hit arcia digging for two here comes the
throw not in time
orlando
yeah he continues to swing a pretty good
bat the veteran comes back swaying and a
miss strike three a low fastball got him
ori is furious with himself slams the
bat down
inning comes to an end and all about the
pitching so far for brandon woodruff
he's yet to allow a hit through four
innings
one two
good start struck him out looking that
slider tonight is nasty
this slider maybe curveball that was 85
miles an hour right on the outside
corner that's a curveball
got him looking 97 at the knees
back-to-back punch-outs for brandon
woodruff
coming back here it is
bullseye struck him out looking
and he strikes out the side
all looking
the 3-2 by lester to nottingham swung on
and miss strike three
one away
one-two runner goes swinging a little
flare that's gonna find greenery
first the third will go taylor and he's
gonna be held at third base
doesn't matter how hard you hit it but
where for garcia who's two for two hit
him where they ain't that's what they
used to say
swinging a miss on a change up he gets
out of it yeah love the emotion
he's got seven strikeouts tonight we're
still tied at zero
miller park no score
sixth inning ian half leads it off it's
a ground ball left side base hit left
center field ian has good speed he'll
round first as garcia gets it back in
it's a single
ian half a leadoff single for the cubs
in the sixth inning it's their first hit
of the game against brandon woodruff
runner and first the pitch
that is on the outside corner and chris
bryant is caught looking
been up three times struck out three
times
that is number eight in the game
for woodruff
swinging a miss
so he's got eight and yelich
struck out all three times
braun grounds to a backhanding corner
john lester
matching brandon woodruff pitch for
pitch through six he is coming out
dominating the night longest outing of
the year for him six and a third that
was in pittsburgh second start of the
year and on o2 a called third strike for
strikeout number 10. brandon woodruff is
just
playing darts brandon woodruff and jacob
nottingham have been
in sync from pitch number one
give him 11 punch outs
this time a swinging strikeout
on another fastball
it's just a lot of fun watching brandon
tonight good old-fashioned pitchers duel
in milwaukee tonight
woodruff
kicks and throws
struck him out looking
ties a career high with a dozen
strikeouts
gets it done
bryant in the air well hit and it is off
the wall
oh so close chris is going to make his
way toward third
safe he's got a triple
a two out triple here in the age
he goes to the right side dunks it in
for a base hit yelich burning for third
he's there with nobody out in the bottom
of the knife
beautiful by jed jericho putting the
ball in play just dumping it out there
in the right field field in that man at
first base jerko that run means nothing
man at third means everything lebron at
the plate over three today
facing jeffers for just the second time
ever fly ball center field and should be
deep enough hayward back makes the catch
yellidge tags and this ball game is over
ryan braun comes through for the
breweries with a sacrifice fly
and the crew takes game one against the
cubs
in this
huge weekend series